We're on problem 21.
Stan's solution to an equation
is shown below.
All right, and I haven't looked
at it yet, but let's
just see what they ask us.
Which statement about Stan's
solution is true?
So let's just work through it
and see if he got it right or
if he made a mistake.
So let's see.
Let's think about it
how we would do it.
So if we had n plus 8 times
n plus 20 is equal to 110.
So the first thing you want to
do is you'd want to distribute
this 8 times n plus 20.
You don't want to multiply
this whole n plus 8.
Remember, you're doing order
of operations, so it's
multiplication first.
Let's do that.
So you get the n plus and
you distribute this 8.
So it's 8n plus 160
is equal to 110.
8 times n plus 8 times
20 is 160.
And already I see a discrepancy
between ours and his.
We have n there.
We have plus 8n there.
But where he has a
20, we have 160.
He didn't distribute the 8.
8 times n plus 20
is 8n plus 160.
So that's wrong.
So he made a mistake
in step 1.
Unfortunately, he got all that
other work that he had to do
just because of his-- it's all
going to be wrong because of
his mistake.
Problem 22.
When is the statement true?
The opposite of a number is less
then the original number.
Well, I mean, if I have a
negative number, the opposite
of a negative is positive.
So it's not going to be less.
But if l positive number, then
the opposite of it is
negative, which is
less than it.
Because a negative is less
than a positive.
Or if we say that x is greater
than 0, then minus x is going
to be less than x.
If we say x is positive,
then definitely.
You know, minus 3 is less
than positive 3.
So the statement is true
for positive numbers.
So that's C.
It's definitely not
never true.
I mean we showed a case
where it's true.
If I have positive 3, negative
3 is less than that.
Statement B.
The statement is always true.
Well no, if we start with
negative 3, the opposite is
going to be larger.
The opposite's going
to be positive 3.
And D.
The statement is true for
negative numbers.
No, it's not.
Negative 3, the opposite is 3.
And that's larger
than negative 3.
Problem 23.
What is the y-intercept
of the graph?
OK, let me see.
So 23.
They say 4x plus 2y
is equal to 12.
So if you were to graph this
line, not that I'm going to--
the y-intercept is when it
intersects the y-axis.
So it's that point there.
It's what's this y-coordinate.
Well the x-coordinate, it's
when x is equal to 0.
So it's going to be 0 comma
some y-intercept.
So the easiest thing to do
is say when x is equal
to 0, what is y?
So when x is equal to 0, this
4 times 0 is equal to 0.
So that just becomes 0.
So you get 2y is equal to 12.
y is equal to 6, and
that's choice C.
All they want to know is, of
this line, when x is equal to
0, what's y?
That's what the y-intercept
is.
Next problem.
OK, they've drawn us a graph.
They say-- let me copy
and paste this one.
OK.
Copied it.
OK, which inequality is shown
on the graph below?
So first of all, let's figure
out the equation of
this line right now.
So what's its y-intercept,
first of all?
So when x is equal to 0,
y is equal to minus 1.
If we put it in slope y
intercept form, the equation
of really, any line is y
is equal to mx plus b.
Where m is the slope and
b is the y-intercept.
Here, when x is 0,
y is negative 1.
So the y-intercept is minus 1.
So b is minus 1.
So we know that y is equal
to mx minus 1.
And now we just have to
figure out the slope.
And the slope is just change in
y for a given change in x.
So if we say change in y for a
given change in x is equal
to-- let's see.
When I increase x by 2,
I increase y by 1.
So change in y is 1 when
the change in x is 2.
And you could say when you
increase x by 4-- I'm going
four spots-- I increase
y by 2.
So you could have done that.
You could have said change in
y over change in x is 2/4,
which is also equal to 1/2.
But either way, we now
know the slope.
The slope is change in
y over change in x.
So the equation of the line is
y is equal to 1/2 x minus 1.
That's the equation
of this line.
Now they want to know what the
equation of the inequality is.
So first of all, they're
including-- they have this
grey area and they put
this line in bold.
So that means that we're
including the line.
If they had drawn a dotted line
here that means we're not
including the line.
But since they're including
the line, it's going to be
either greater than or less
than or equal to.
That equal to is because we're
including the line.
But just think about it.
So our choices are y is greater
than or equal to 1/2 x
minus 1 or y is less than or
equal to 1/2 x minus 1.
Now think about for
any given x.
Let's say when x
is equal to 2.
When x is equal to 2, if you put
it into this equation you
get y is equal to 0 and that's
this point on the line.
Now is the grey area all y
values greater than 0 or all y
values less than 0?
Well clearly, it's all y
values greater than 0.
It's all the y values
above the y value
dictated by this equation.
The equation of this inequality
or this area is y
is greater than 1/2 x minus 1.
And just a very easy way to
eyeball it is OK, they're
including the line, so I'm
going to have this equal
then-- it's going to either be
greater than or equal to or
less than or equal to, and since
it's the area above the
line it's going to be greater
than or equal to.
And that is choice D.
Next problem, problem 25.
This is another one where I
think it makes sense to copy
and paste it.
It's a big one.
OK.
Which best represents
the graph of y id
equal to 2x minus 2.
So the slope is 2.
Its positive 2 and its
y-intercept is minus 2.
So the y-intercept is
easy to eyeball.
Here the y-intercept
is minus 2.
That's right.
Here it's minus 2 as well.
In both of these, the
y-intercept is plus 2.
So neither of these are
going to, right?
It intersects the y-axis
at positive 2.
But we know that the y-intercept
is minus 2.
So we know-- whoops.
Where'd I go?
There we go.
So we know our choices are
one of the top two.
It's either A or C.
And which of these has
a positive slope,
positive slope of 2?
Well in choice A when I go to
the right by 2, I go up by 4.
So change in y over
change in x.
I go up by 4, when I
go up in x by 2.
I go up in y by 4 when I go up
in x by 2, so the slope is 2.
So this has a positive slope
of 2, so that's choice A.
But just for seeing why choice C
doesn't work or figuring out
the slope, think about
it this way.
Let me start at a random
point here.
If I increase x value
by 2, what's
happening to my y value?
Is it increasing by 2 or
is it decreasing by 2?
Well it's decreasing.
Well it's decreasing by 4.
It's decreasing at
twice the rate.
It's decreasing by 4.
So in this case, change
in y over change in x.
Whenever x is positive 2,
we increased by 2 here.
What happened to y.
It went down 4.
So here the slope is minus 2.
And you can look at that.
You can kind of eyeball it
because it's going from the
top left to the bottom right,
so it's going to
be a negative number.
But the easiest way I always do
is to draw these arrows and
say, OK, when I increase
x, y is decreasing.
So that's going to be
a negative slope.
Let's do it.
So the answer was A.
Next problem.
OK, so they're giving us another
one of these where
they shaded a graph.
These are good.
Thank God I have the cut
and paste feature.
So they ask us, which inequality
does the shaded
region of the graph represent?
So once again, it'll be good
just to figure out what the
equation of this line is.
We could immediately say, OK,
the y-intercept is 2.
And what's its slope?
When x increases by 1,
what happens to y?
y is going down by 3.
So the y-intercept
is equal to 2.
We figured that out.
b is equal to 2.
The slope is equal to change
in y over change in x.
When x increases by 1,
the slope-- sorry.
The change in y is minus 3.
It goes down by 3.
So the slope is equal
to minus 3.
So the equation of this
line is y is equal to
minus 3x plus 2.
mx plus b.
And if I look at the choices,
already it looks a little bit
different than that, but
we'll get to that.
But let's see what the
inequality is.
So first of all, it's going to
be either greater than or
equal or less than or equal.
And we say the or equal
because they
filled in the line.
So let's think about it.
If we pick any x, say when x is
equal to 2, then according
to this equation, according
to this line, y would be
equal to minus 4.
Now, are we including the y's
that are greater than that
value as well or are we
including the y's that are
less than that value?
Well, we're including the ones
that are less than that point
for a given x.
So the shaded region is y
is less than or equal to
minus 3x plus 2.
And you can eyeball this.
You can kind of say, oh, this
is below the graph, so it's
less than or equal.
And that equal was because
they shaded in the line.
If it was a dotted line it
would just be less than.
Once again, this isn't
the exact format
that they have here.
They put all the x's and the y's
on the same side, and we
can do that.
Let's just add 3x to both sides
of this equation and you
get 3x plus y is less
than or equal to.
When you add 3x on the
right-hand side that
just becomes 0.
So less than or equal to 2.
And that is 3x plus y is less
than or equal to positive 2.
And that is choice A.
And I'm all out of time, see
you in the next video.